all right we're getting into our
post-election patriot mail and there's
been a sort of a shift it's less about
Hillary Trump and it's getting more into
issues and back to the personal attacks
that we've grown to love and fear I
guess is the best ways to describe that
I'll remind you of course what hatred
mail is it's like email for words from
your racist grandma on steroids Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America because freedom
so many new words have been coined
either by people in our audience or by
david pakman show staff accidentally of
course the term hatred itself is one
that is now in urban dictionary the term
a fever n't a combination of fervent and
feverish is one that former producer
lewis accidentally used which is now an
urban dictionary
today's hatred hell contains a word that
I really like I've never heard this word
before and and we're gonna take a listen
now you got a lot to learn Pakman I
think a few years behind bars with nips
will resolve your education issues you
won't make it a week without a fight
when these murders get your asses in a
corner they're gonna kill you and maybe
even with the help of their Mexicans
you'll wish you had been more racist
black people are fundamentally violent
black people and Jews need to be kept in
line it is not same dope Abeka zento
phobia i think that this is some
horribly depraved and perverted version
of xenophobia right that's what i'm
getting Zenta phobia and I would have
pronounced it Zenta favi Kurr
when I saw the word I thought Zenta
phobic abut of course the professional
voice-over artist who I deferred to on
pronunciation says that it's zento fo
Beca well he is right in the sense that
it's not zento fo because either have
you ever seen anything like this Zenta
fo Beca no but it didn't surprise me
after I read the word fundamentally
fundamentally
it's fundamentally not Zenta phobe iike
patriots almost speak their own language
I mean it's it's it's very very odd and
they have their own logic - I know yeah
I would being more racist help you to
avoid fights with Blacks and Jews yeah
more racism helps to reduce race-based
fighting apparently according to this
hatred listen you could always turn
hatred mail into something positive you
can say fu to the hey tree 'it's by
using membership coupon code hey tree at
40 all one word h8 er IOT 4-0 at david
pakman.com slash membership and that
will give you a 40% discount off of
membership